روما المدينة الخالدة
، لا تزال الهياكل القديمة قائمة
قبلها شمس الصيف الدافئة
بعد آلاف السنين ، لا يزال هناك
الكثير للكشف عن
الكنوز تحت الأقدام التي دفنوها في جميع
أنحاء إيطاليا.
ينتقل
هذا المتحف في الهواء الطلق من جيل إلى جيل ، وهو بمثابة إغراء
لأولئك الذين يؤمنون بالربح على
الإرث
أثناء زيارة الفيلا الإمبراطورية للإمبراطور الروماني نيرو الواقعة على
شاطئ البحر والتي تقع
جنوب روما مباشرة ،
وتعثرت عبر هذا الرجل الذي
وصل إلى السياج المحيط به وكان على
ما يبدو  التنقيب عن الكنز في وضح
النهار ، تم استدعاء الشرطة وتم
توبيخ الرجل وتحرك يمينًا
أمامنا ،
وقالت الشرطة إنه ادعى أنه كان يبحث
عن البلاستيك في
هذه الفيلا القديمة مثل العديد من المواقع الأخرى التي
لم يتم التنقيب فيها بالكامل
عن كنوزها ما زالت مدفونة
تحت الأرض  جاهزة للنهب
القطع الأثرية المسروقة في نهاية المطاف في جميع أنحاء
العالم من المتحف الرئيسي  ms إلى المجموعات الخاصة
تم تسمية نجمة الواقع كيم كارداشيان ويست
مؤخرًا في ملفات المحكمة بشأن
تمثال روماني تمت مصادرته في عام
2016 من
قبل الجمارك وحماية الحدود الأمريكية ،
قال متحدث باسم كارداشيان ويست إنها
لم تقم بشراء هذه القطعة مطلقًا والجهود
جارية لإعادتها إلى  روما
بلغت قيمة السوق العالمية للفنون
والآثار 50 مليار دولار في عام 2020.
وفقًا للسلطات ، كان هناك ما
لا يقل عن 20 مليون دولار أمريكي من
القطع الأثرية الإيطالية التي تم الاتجار بها العام الماضي ، الناس
يريدون المشاركة في التاريخ ،
يريد الناس امتلاك التاريخ
ومن الواضح أنك تريد  للقيام بذلك بشكل
شرعي ، فأنت تريد أن تذهب إلى
السلطات المختصة في بيوت المزادات المناسبة
التي يمكن أن تقول إنني
أضمن أن ما
تشتريه له بروفيدانس
داريوس آريا هو عالم آثار مدرب تم سرقة حفرياته
، ويقول إنه ليس مجرد  tombaroli الذين
هم
المجرمين يذهبون طوال الطريق في السلسلة الغذائية
إلى عبادة carabinieri الإيطالية للمشتري
يعود الفضل لقوة شرطة أورال في
إعادة كنوز إيطاليا المسروقة
في عام 2020 ، حيث تمكنت الشرطة الثقافية الإيطالية
من إعادة
500000 قطعة مسروقة في غضون عام واحد
فقط ، حيث
يوجد ضرر مزدوج عندما
يأخذ تومبارولي الأشياء
من مقبرة أو معرض في هذا
البلد الأول هو الضرر الاقتصادي
، والقيمة الفنية والتاريخية ، والثاني هو ما
نسميه
وضع سياق لموقع
حيث يسرقون علماء الآثار من
تتبع تاريخ السلام
[موسيقى]
في هذا القبو في العالم المركزي ،
والفن المسروق الذي أعيد من الجميع  حول العالم
تم تصنيفها وتنظيفها وإعدادها
لمنزل جديد ،
يقول ستيفانو أليساندريني إنه عمل على
إعادة آلاف القطع الأثرية
نصف مليون ، إنه أمر لا يصدق ، لكن العديد
من
الأشياء من أرشيفات المكتبات ،
الكثير منها أشياء صغيرة ولكن أيضًا
الشيء الصغير مهم جدًا
لتاريخنا  لذلك
من الصعب للغاية مراقبة
كل هذه الكنوز والتنقيب عنها
ولا يوجد نقص في المشترين
شهد الوباء زيادة في المبيعات عبر الإنترنت في
إيطاليا التي تكافح للحفاظ على تراثها الثقافي
كنزًا تلو الآخر